The page is starting to look more like the design,
but we're still missing the image.
To use the image, you have to store it somewhere where the page can access it.
Make a folder called images inside your Project folder and put the image there.
Make sure the image name does not contain any spaces or accented characters or
else, it will make linking to it more difficult.
You can add the image to the page with the tag img and
providing the source of the image, like so.
You should also always provide this alt attribute, which displays alternate
information to the screen in case the browser cannot display the image.
Once you have added the image,
the page look a lot more like the actual design mock.
But how does our page still differ from the design mock?
Is the header background and text color still different?
Are the margins and padding for the boxes still different?
What about the borders of the boxes?
What about the font size and style?
Do we still need to update those?